World War II is a little hyperbolic I I
don't foresee Russia getting involved
although it could happen something like
that we're already in a massive proxy
war against Russia right now as we all
know which is uh horrifying and
terrifying um but they're not that close
with the Ayatollah you know Russia and
Iran they have their own tensions going
back and they've been getting along okay
and and Iran has been sending drones for
the Russian war effort and that kind of
thing but they don't have like a treaty
of Alliance where Russia would go to war
for Iran and quite frankly I think
think I think worst case scenario here
the war spreads to Lebanon and possibly
Iraq but I really think that the
Americans and and the ayat Tois guys too
have got to be cautioning him and I
think the American Military has got to
be telling Joe Biden how badly they do
not want to fight Ira Iran you put that
map up earlier there that country's what
three four times the size of Afghanistan